Speaker 1: Let's talk about free speech, truth,
social, which Donald Trump misstated as true
social. At a rally a week ago, it is the Trump
social media platform which the people on the
right who like the platform promote as a free
speech platform. Now, this this should already
set off an alarm in our heads because most
platforms describe themselves by what they are,
not by the vague term free speech platform. So
like YouTube is a video platform. I don't know
exactly what their current tagline is, but
it's the biggest video video sharing site in
the world. To call it a free speech platform
would be kind of weird. It's a video platform
and they have terms of service that people
have to abide by. Okay. Facebook is the biggest
social whatever platform and free speech platform
to me would signal it's almost like a penis size
contest where it's some. The thing you say to
get attention for that. And when we talk about
truth social and we actually look at their
terms of service, it turns out they have the
exact same guidelines as any other platform. And
so when I hear free speech platform, I think it's
a platform for speech that they like. Check this
out. Here are all of the different reasons that
you can report a post untruth, social, a based on
their terms of service and terms and conditions.
If you see illegal activity content that depicts
illegal or criminal acts or threats of violence,
okay, that's standard. Every platform has
that intellectual property infringement,
impersonating another account or business
infringing on intellectual property rights. Well,
that's UN adjudicated. So someone can
just assert that there is some kind of
infringement and you don't even go through
due process to prove it and the content can
be removed. Wow. That's that doesn't sound like
the free speech platform they claim it to be,
but it does sound like basically every other
platform on the Internet. Sensitive content.
If there is violence, gore or nudity, the content
can be pulled. Oh, so like every other platform,
if there's underage content, sexually explicit
content involving underage children. Oh,
that's just like on YouTube, just like
on Facebook, just like on Twitter,
prostitution, any solicitation or advertising
for illegal sexual activity or sex for hire? Hmm.
Any privacy violation if you violate or post
content that violates a person's privacy rights
just like every other platform, illegal
sales. If you sell or promote illegal drugs,
counterfeit services and goods or illegal products
and services. Well, even counterfeit, isn't it?
The buyer beware freedom for whoever wants to
engage in commerce to decide, I want to buy this
and maybe it's a fake product or not, but that
that that's not exactly free speech. And lastly,
doxing sharing or threatening to share private
information of individuals without their consent.
So basically it's a lot of cancel culture. Now
I'm joking. In reality, it's the exact same stuff
we see on every platform. Interestingly, Truth
Social has welcomed and become a sort of de facto
safe haven for a lot of the people who supported
the riots on January 6th, 2021, supported the
coup, supported the insurrection by their
own terms of service. All of that information
and depictions of what was done would have to be
removed by truth social. And we have to understand
that a free speech platform is a
red alert alarm that they mean,
speech we like and are choosing to coddle. Now,
after the disastrous launch of the platform,
it seems as though now they've explained to Trump,
Sir, you've got to be a little more involved here.
And Trump finally made his first post,
Untruth Social months after it launched.
And the message is, I'm back hashtag cub ffe
and it features a picture of Trump using his
phone in front of Mar a Lago in Palm
Beach, Florida, and it seems to have been
potentially removed from Twitter. There was
a picture of the post on Twitter, so it's not
even really clear Trump cares about this thing. I
think he knows there's not very many people on it.
It's probably just another gif, a grift or cash
grab. So truth social. Not that much free speech.
Trump's not even really on the platform,
and it's yet another way to take advantage
of their followers who seem more than thrilled
about opportunities to be taken advantage of.